remember what the goal of the
narcissistic person is in a relationship
to get supply
right so if they want someone supplied
they meet someone new that they want to
date or they're interested or want to
flirt with they have a business
associate or
investor they want to win over there
when they
want something from someone or they want
something to look a certain way
they know what to do and this is what
upsets and angers people in these
relationships you're like
they know what to do i'm watching them
do it with someone else
why can't they do it with me i'm like
because they don't want your supply they
want their supply
and so they're not going to do it you
know it's like i'm not going to give
someone a dollar for something i don't
want to buy
but i'm going to give it to someone else
when i want to buy it that's what that's
how they are with supply and so
yes they know what to do this idea of
mirroring them nails it because it's
as though they know what like the
pleases and the thank yous and the
listening and the uh-huh or that sounds
hard
it's it's like putting on a show or
putting on a play and it's actually
falls into something we call
cognitive empathy cognitive empathy is
sort of the
sort of like splenda to sugar kind of
thing it's not the real thing and it
doesn't feel or taste as good and so
it's more of the um it's the
it's the it's the knowing what empathy
is knowing like i'm supposed to listen
to this person and i'm supposed to tell
them i feel bad and i'm
or i'm supposed to like really tell them
they're great i'm supposed to
right and so and in fact ironically
people who are narcissistic will often
cry
at movies but yet then you'll be in real
life with them you're like
this is like real pain six inches from
you and you're talking about a random
person in a movie
because when when emotion is in their
space
they're threatened by it because they
don't feel like they can manage it
but when it's a story remember all they
do have a lot of emotion in them
that's a safer place to express it and
people misread that oh they cried at the
movie
what a sweet emotional person i'm like
no
it's cognitive empathy booby prize uh
explain
i think this is also fascinating because
there's such that initial part in a
relationship
with the narcissist that um probably in
almost anyone but definitely more of a
romantic one where
uh you know the love bombing and so you
know this love
bombing devalued discard hoover sort of
loop um i think this would be
fascinating for people to understand but
especially that love bombing
stuff so the love bombing is the it's a
grandiose show
often grandiose but not always and i'll
explain that not always but
it's it's a it's this intense attention
the narcissist will pay
in the early part of a relationship
frequent texting
never met anyone like this i feel a
magical connection to you
they use this grandiose non-specific
language
you're sort of swept away can feel very
romantic if they've got the means they
may send you flowers or gifts or
come up with elaborate experiences what
it's all doing in a way it's blinding a
person to the red flags
all of this excitement's happening you
may be missing sort of that
they sometimes are a little distracted
on their phone or they're still doing
some shady stuff or
they don't regret themselves they showed
up late or they're sort of rude to a
person who valet parked their car or
something like that that you'll say
oh well no no i'm overthinking it or
maybe i'm the one who's afraid of
commitment i finally found someone who's
paying attention to me
and now i'm trying to find red flags
there's something wrong with me
and whereas i'm thinking again red flags
a red flag what's interesting is that
the other thing that can happen during
love bombing
is there can be this really intense of
like tell me your deepest
fear and they t you know why they're
taking all that
they're putting it in a backpack so they
can use it against you
and then you think you're entering this
deep intimate sense of someone
and you're basically handing them the
knives they're going to use to stab you
with
and then when you ask for their deepest
the
it's nothing you get nothing it's
nothing or they give you a falsehood
because then it won't hurt them if you
did actually attempt to hit them back
so another way love bombing can happen
is they will present a very overly
victimized story of their lives like
my life has been so hard my life has
been so tough and
rescuers will say oh my gosh you need a
place to live come over with me or you
need a car like i don't always use my
car
and before you know it there's people
who are actually now turning around and
covert narcissists tend to play that
game a little bit more
very victimized love bombing and people
feel like
i want to rescue them and they really do
well with people who are hyper empaths
so that's the love bombing phase that
can last
anywhere usually for six weeks to three
months i've heard people telling me it's
lasted for five years i've heard it
lasting for six to twelve months
but usually somewhere in the
neighborhood maybe three to four months
is about average
because that's about all they can keep
it up for then
once they and a lot of people will even
be resistant and say like oh they're so
into me i can
you know i can even like i could be
chilling or you know i don't i can play
this game with them
but then what will happen is they'll
start losing a little steam you're like
okay
i'm into you and you move things too
fast narcissistic relationships
more often than not move too fast people
move in too fast they get engaged too
fast they talk about marriage too fast
they travel together too fast they move
to another city too fast
too fast and why because the narcissist
needs to get you to the point where they
can devalue you
once you agree to them they have believe
it or not such
low self-esteem like if you want to be
with me you can't be all that is
actually probably what's happening deep
inside of them
but what they have you is they have you
where they need you your narcissistic
supply starting to get a little bit
stale
because you're not something they need
to fight for you're not feeding their
ego
so now they may have a roving eye they
may be much more distractible
they may be much more likely to pull out
your point out your flaws
but at this point a person still feels
very much in love now they're justifying
then we go to the discard now the
devalue phase can last for years to be
honest oh yeah that's all those forms of
abuse
years gaslighting that's manipulation
now the discard may or may not be a
breakup a lot of people think does this
card mean they move out no not
necessarily
discard may mean they go and have an
affair and they're very much
out of the relationship the discard may
mean that really they become so
neglectful they don't even know you're
alive like they just don't care they
don't care about anything about you
the discard may be you wanting to leave
the relationship ironically because
you've had it
but it's either a relationship rupture
or it's you have been literally replaced
and you're sitting there thinking like
okay let's go to counseling since you're
having your 10th affair kind of thing
and so that's discard at the discard
phase either they've left
you've left or there's been a split
there's
been a split well now the narcissistic
person who doesn't like abandonment and
doesn't like
not being in control now you can start
the hoovering process
which maybe the narcissist even went and
had an affair or even found a new
relationship
well you know that's not going to last
forever or they don't like the idea that
you're moving on with your life
so you'll get that late night text maybe
i'm just thinking about you
or miss you or you'll get what i always
call the anniversary date hoover
maybe it is your anniversary maybe it's
a birthday christmas thanksgiving some
other holiday
and they'll use that of thinking about
you on new year's eve they'll use those
as entry points and those can often be
lonely times for people
that then starts to hoover back in and
then the whole cycle starts again
now not everybody's hoovered and some
people out there think i wasn't hoovered
was i not even good enough to be
hoovered i'm like
count yourself amongst the lucky be glad
sometimes the hoover happens five and
ten years later
where hopefully a person sort of moved
on and healed
but um but that's the cycle and so
you know i always say to people if you
really want to have like a fling with a
narcissist it's like eating the top off
a cupcake go for it just get out in six
weeks
you know and then you're out before
there's been any damage and maybe you
had a good time
but the longer you're in the more the
narcissistic person frankly is gonna
view that they need to control you
so if you try to leave during the love
bombing phase
you're gonna be either heavily hoovered
or they're going to do a smear campaign
on you and they're going to speak
disparagingly of you on social media to
maybe mutual people you know
so there's really no winning in this so
in all seriousness you don't even need
the top of the cupcake the minute you
see the red flags
get out while the getting is good